after weeks of will they won't they
speculation we have the answer Harry's
coming that Megan isn't a coronation
compromise and this is a big decision it
would have been pretty Unthinkable
um and almost done known in history for
uh the second son not to attend the
father's coronation uh so it looks like
they've managed by hook or by group to
actually come up with a solution
it's a solution that took many months to
reach confirmed in just two short
sentences the Duke of Sussex will attend
the coronation service at Westminster
Abbey on May the 6th The Duchess of
Sussex will remain in California with
Prince Archie and Princess Lily butt no
detail on what made up their minds but
Harry claimed in recent interviews there
was a lot to discuss before he decided
he'd wanted to sit down and talk with
his family we don't know if that
happened but he was in the UK last month
at the high court for his case against
the daily mail's publishers
as for Megan her absence is significant
but the coronation coincides with
Archie's fourth birthday it shows that
there's a willingness to compromise on
the part of the uh the Sussex couple
um and understand the importance of
history in that the Royal Dukes are a
really important part of the family
um but I think it also means that
there's very much an independence that's
in place for Harry and Megan that
they're not really going to compromise
on at least not at present
but at least coming alone the Duke of
Sussex avoids awkward moments and some
of the uncomfortable speculation this is
perhaps the outcome the royal family
privately hoped for there were fears the
presence of both sussexes here would
have created a media circus distracting
and diverting attention away from the
coronation the family Rift seems far
from resolved but for now the king
probably just relieved he'll have both
sons present for his crowning moment
Laura bundock Sky News